what's shaking you nazis
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for february
4th 21 and uh i am
very much in the mood to do a show today
i'm actually always in the mood to do
the show
it's very rare that i'm not sometimes
i'm like ah
another stupid story about cnn some
other nonsensical
ridiculous thing happening that i have
to talk about but i do love doing this i
really do
but just sitting down with these stories
in the last half hour reviewing this
stuff we added a story at the last
second because there's so much
like crazy breaking nonsense i was like
i am really in the mood
to deliver the info to the people today
so let's do it there's a lot to get to
uh as always guys just don't forget to
click that subscribe button something's
going on
with the powers that be over at youtube
and people keep getting unsubscribed and
real quick
before we get to all of it guys it's
february
and if you're looking forward to a
valentine's day but not sure how to stay
away from the candy
i've got just the solution for you built
bar people not billbar built bar
if you can get built by if you get
billbar though for for uh valentine's
day i guess that would be pretty good
built bar is the secret to eating
healthier food while also eating tastier
food
built bars are low calorie low sugar
high protein high fiber
great for the keto diet you can actually
lose or maintain weight while indulging
in
a yummy treat healthy has never been
this delicious
bilt bars taste like candy and come in
18 amazing flavors including caramel
brownie and peanut butter
my personal favorite as you know is the
cookies and cream i am a simple man
built bars are covered in 100 chocolate
include both nut
and nut free flavors and are soft and
easy to chew i know with restaurants
finally opening up
it'll be tempting to indulge but we also
need to shed those additional quarantine
pounds
which is why built bars are the perfect
alternative to pie
for the health conscious guy each bar is
about 110 to 160 calories you're gonna
get 16 to 20 grams of protein
three to five net carbs it's only
february guys don't give up on the new
year's resolution
built bars are the answer go to
builtbar.com
and use promo code ruben to get 20 off
your next order use promo code ruben
for 20 off at builtbar.com and i wonder
if you go to billbar.com and enter code
ruben who knows what would happen
you know what i mean give that a try and
let me know in the comments right down
below
okay guys we're doing four stories today
we added one just at the last second
because
this jen pasaki she is a piece of work
the white house press secretary uh so we
had to add a story on that because i saw
some video from the press conference
this morning and these people
that govern us are ridiculous human
beings they are just
absolutely completely ridiculous but
speaking of completely ridiculous human
beings the aclu
uh the american civil liberties what
does the u stand for
american civil liberties not university
what does it stand for american civil
liberties
you union union the american civil
liberties
union acl they're a union all right uh
well they used to be a pretty great
organization so let me get the joking
part out of the way quick
the aclu used to be a phenomenal
organization they fought
for free speech there is the landmark
case that you've probably heard me talk
about before
and i had the former head of the aclu
nadine strassen on to talk about
which was the incredible case back in
the early 70s i think it was 71 maybe it
was 72
which was skokie versus illinois where a
bunch of neo-nazis wanted to march
in skokie illinois this was a place
where i think it was the largest
concentration of holocaust survivors in
the united states
and the aclu actually defended their
right to do that
defended their right to express
themselves defended their right to free
speech despite
the intentional provocation despite the
fact that they went exactly to where all
these holocaust survivors were
all of the hurt feelings all of that
stuff the aclu defended their right to
do it they
said you can't do it violently but you
have a right to express themselves
that's
that's a pretty uh what i would say is a
deeply
moral position to take and not one
that's easy to do right it's easy
to make easy decisions it's hard to make
hard decisions right so the aclu which
has defended free speech forever
uh if you've been paying attention in
the last two three years has gone
completely woke
and they have just absolutely thrown
rationality
and thought through the window in the
name of social justice
and just the endless litany of woke
lunacy that
you guys hear about so they put out a
twitter thread yesterday
and now before i read you the twitter
thread and i'll editorialize as i'm
reading it
uh let's not forget that just yesterday
we covered a story how on
cnn they had a legal expert on saying
that lying
is not protected by the first amendment
now they did not correct that on cnn
because cnn is not a place of journalism
the the woman herself she actually did
send out a tweet saying that she
basically misspoke it was
wasn't really an apology or anything uh
but on cnn so if you're an average
watcher of cnn you might think now that
they brought on a legal expert who said
you're not allowed to lie
and lying is against the first amendment
well i want you to work with me here and
let's go through all the lies in this
aclu thread it's a four tweet
thread here uh first myth sex is
binary apparent at birth and
identifiable through singular
biological characteristics that's
actually not a myth that's that's true
but here's what they go on to say
there is no one way for our bodies to be
women including women who are
transgender intersex or disabled have a
range of different
physical characteristics okay that
that's just not
true right when when you go and have a
baby what's the first thing they do the
baby
you got a boy you got a girl are these
doctors all transphobes like what's
happening there they go on to say
biological sex and gender
are not binaries there are no set
hormone ranges body parts or chromosomes
that all people of a particular sex or
gender have
yeah again guys this is not true and you
don't need to be a scientist
or a mathemagician to figure it out uh
guys have
penises women have vaginas okay that's
just
kind of right that doesn't mean that you
can't identify as another gender
and go ahead and transition in which
case i will treat you with respect if
you treat me with respect
but telling us that science doesn't
exist no that's that's i know that's
part of the destruction that we're
seeing of everything that
we once held dear but no no no it's not
right so myth that was that was their
first tweet in the thread and basically
you can see it's complete nonsense
myth two we'll continue with the
nonsense trans athletes
physiological characteristics provide an
unfair advantage over cis
athletes trans athletes vary in athletic
ability just like cisgender athletes
in many states the very same cis girls
who have claimed that trans athletes
have an unfair advantage have
consistently performed as well or better
than transgender competitors
first off when they talk about cis what
they mean is that if you are
born a biological woman woman and you
identify
as a woman then you're cis like you're
you're cisgendered you are in the body
you're supposed to be in
now this is also nonsense you have all
seen
the videos of biological males who
trans uh transition to female
and then they crush the girls in
wrestling because they are much bigger
they out compete them in racing they
dunk over them
in basketball by the way that is not to
say
that men are inherently better than
women we are
born with different things that gets to
myth one that they lied about
we are just born differently men are
generally stronger
men are generally bigger and once you
transition
although you still have the same
biological body parts yeah you're
generally going to be stronger than all
of these people so congratulations to
all of the feminists
who are now all about the trans movement
who are going to in essence
have a bunch of biological men
winning all of the athletic awards for
females so they butchered number two
as well here's myth three which is right
off that one
myth the participation of trans athletes
hurts
cis women excluding women who are trans
hurts all women
it invites gender policing that could
subject any woman to invasive tests
or accusations of being too masculine or
too good at the sport to be a real woman
i mean i have no idea what they're
talking about here you know not that
anyone watches the nba but years ago i
watched a little bit right when it
started
there was this incredible woman on the
houston comets
cynthia cooper she was sort of older at
the time when the league just started
but she was phenomenal and i actually
did enjoy watching her and there's
there's obviously some very good
athletes there
actually sue bird who's i think like
thought of as maybe the best
uh wnba player in their 20-year history
went to the same high school
i played on on the street with her a
couple times like at the parks and stuff
so this is not disrespect to to girls
that like basketball actually michael
my producer his sister is a pretty
awesome basketball player and she came
here and she woke my ass and horse a
couple weeks ago which i'm still pissed
about
so this has nothing to do with whether
girls are good at things or some girls
are better than boys at things or any of
that stuff
but this is complete nonsense excluding
women who are trans hurt all women
no it doesn't if you are biologically
something then either you should play
in the biological league of which you
were born into meaning if you were
biologically male then play in the male
league
or le if there are that many trans
people out there then let's have
as we have a male division and a female
division let's have a trans division
but the idea that no it won't affect um
biological cisgendered women at all if
you let all these guys in there it's
just like
guys like give logic a chance
a little air and myth for
trans students need separate teams so
this is what i just addressed
trans people like all people may
experience detrimental effects to their
physical and emotional well-being when
they are pushed out of affirming spaces
and communities well that is true at
some level right we all
like to be part of groups that are
somewhat similar to
us right whether that's a sport group or
a reading club or a knitting club or
whatever it might be
which is why i just said if if they want
their own if trans people want their own
sports group so you have your male
division your female division and your
trans division i guess you'd have to
have two trans divisions right
because you'd have to have female to
male trans division sports and male to
female trans so now we've got four
divisions and i'm sure we can divide
that up further it goes on to say
efforts to exclude subsets of girls
from sports can undermine team unity and
youth derive the most benefits from
athletics when they are exposed to
caring environments where teammates are
supported by each other and by coaches
look i think you guys got the point here
the aclu is no longer
anything close to what it was it is now
a woke organization pushing social
justice on everybody i want to just be
very clear i've said this a million
times and and i know you morons at media
matters that are watching this
trying to figure out how you can peg me
as anti-trans or something
i have no problem with trans people if
you are an adult and you
decide to transition uh then then god
bless you and you know what i'll treat
you with respect if you'll treat
me with respect that's what i always say
um but
the simple truth is that if you think
you are
being for women as you were having
biological men put into women's
athletics
then you got another thing coming listen
i'm 44. i have a torn acl
in my in my left knee which i'm thinking
about getting the surgery for and a few
of you have actually a few doctors have
even reached out because i mentioned on
the show once
um i would love to play in the nba i
really would i know i'm never going to
play in the nba and i know at the height
of my basketball career i wasn't even
remotely close even though i do have a
pretty good finger roll
uh but perhaps i will transition to
female and play in the
wnba next season or just wait until a
washed up
41 year old guy scoring two points a
game
who was a scrub in the nba just says
okay i'm going to transition and i'm
going to be a 30-point scorer
mvp in the wnba is that what you people
want i know it all sounds ridiculous
it all sounds ridiculous but this is the
ridiculous path
they are leading us down science does
not matter to these people they have
decided
to put science reality and facts
underneath something known as social
justice
so that they can rejigger society into
some way that they think
is better and what it will do is
actually destroy women
it'll it'll destroy men as well right i
mean and and it will make
people resentful actually of trans
people and that i think
is not what you want i think that's not
what you want anyway don't give money
to the aclu it's it's a really
embarrassing organization at this point
and just because something once was good
doesn't mean it always
will remain good and i think the aclu is
a perfect example of that
uh but speaking of uh sort of the war on
reality that i've been talking about for
quite some time the new york times which
also it's not really a place of
journalism anymore
maybe it was 20 years ago although a lot
of my conservative friends say dave you
just weren't
awoke to it you you had not realized it
yet but it was crap all the time
i don't know that it was fully crap all
the time i think they used to have more
plurality of voices and i also think
that we all know that the woke-ism thing
has just completely infected the entire
thing
i mean even one of the last 20 remaining
decent liberals barry weiss had to leave
the new york times that tells you
how radical it has become um
and the new york times wrote a piece oh
well first off this is a side part of
this story
but i saw this this morning uh mike
solano who's an interesting voice on
twitter
who i've gotten to know a little bit he
tweeted out that there was an article
in today's new york times about um
how they should start looking into
censoring perhaps
apps like telegram and signal because
that's where all the bad guys
are going right now and it's so
interesting because it's like oh
you i'm sure some of you remember this
those of you that have been with me for
a while remember about two years ago
when i was on the cover of the sunday
new york times with jordan peterson and
ben shapiro and joe rogan and
phil defranco and milton friedman the
libertarian economist i think he's a
nobel prize winner
and that we were all leading people to
the alt right so what the new york times
does is they frame it like oh these are
all the bad guys and then you flash
forward two years
and now they're writing pieces about oh
people who might like those guys
actually should be censored on these
apps too and we know that parlor was
just
nuked so it's like are they going to
nuke telegram or whatever else
anyway that's not even the story i'm
covering right now because there's lots
going a lot going on here the new york
times had a piece
how the biden administration can help
solve
our reality crisis and there's a a bunch
of highlights i want to get to here
hoaxes lies and collective delusions
aren't new
but the extent to which millions of
americans have embraced them maybe
the muddled chaotic information
ecosystem that produces these misguided
beliefs
doesn't just jeopardize some lofty ideal
of national unity
it actively exacerbates our biggest
national problems
and creates more work for those trying
to solve them and it raises an important
question for the bidet administration
how do you unite a country in which
millions of people have chosen to create
their own
version of reality uh and finally
joan donovan the research director at
harvard university's shorenstein center
on media politics
and public policy suggested that the
biden administration
could set up a truth commission similar
to the 911 commission
man these people love commissions they
love regulators they love hearings
it's all drivel and nonsense nothing
ever comes of any of it
now what's interesting about this is
what the new york times in essence is
saying here if you don't believe
all the news that's fit to print in our
paper right that was the tagline of the
new york times all the news that's fit
to print
but what they really mean is all the
news that's fit to print that fits
within our narrative and if you guys
who suffer from misinformation and
disinformation and you watch
youtube and you listen to podcasts and
you watch the joe rogan program
you're scary people how are we going to
reprogram you and i've done a couple
shows in the last few weeks on people
talking about how we are going to
reprogram people i mean this is what
they're literally talking about on cnn
while they're also talking about
how they can get fox news knocked off
the air this is what katie couric who i
suppose was a journalist at one time
is talking about how we can deal with
the misinformation and how we can
reprogram people
and then the times but the thing is we
could do the exact same thing here i
mean this is the irony that these people
don't understand
i believe it is my belief as a
sentient human being that the new york
times and cnn are basically pure
propaganda at this point they have
exposed themselves relentlessly
so i could sit here and literally read
the exact same thing from our
perspective actually i'll do it real
quick and you just tell me if it fits
within uh the world view that you might
have talking about
see the the lies of cnn the new york
times
huffpo and the rest of them hoaxes lies
and collective delusions aren't new
but the extent to which millions of
americans have embraced them maybe boy
that sounds right
the muddled chaotic information
ecosystem that produces these misguided
beliefs doesn't just jeopardize
some lofty ideal of national unity it
actively exacerbates our biggest
national problems
and creates more work for those trying
to solve them and it raises an important
question for the biden administration
how to unite a country in which millions
of people have chose to create their own
versions of reality
boy that's true cnn and the new york
times really are doing that
msnbc is doing it too let's not forget
old ali velchi standing in front of
a riot with you know literally a burning
building exploding behind him telling us
it's mostly peaceful
so they are the purveyors of this
nonsense i don't need a harvard
university
uh professor or researcher to tell me
that they're lying to me they're lying
to all of us
moving on okay so this is the one that i
saw right before we started it's just a
piece of work so jen pasaki
is the white house press secretary she's
not very good at her job she seems
fairly
incompetent but of course the media
loves her i covered yesterday
that cnn's one of their chief political
analysts
david axelrod he thinks she's doing a
really great job
of course he did work in the obama
administration and joe biden was the bp
in that administration but he's totally
impartial as a cnn analyst
these are serious people doing serious
work and bringing you the truth
uh so jen pasaki uh was asked today more
about
what's gonna happen after we're all
vaccinated and
uh i should just warn you guys maybe
just get into your seat
and kind of just really get in there and
if you have a bag near you in case you
vomit you might want a bag
and probably move the dog or the cat
because you don't want to kick them here
we go
what we're also trying to do is make our
health and medical experts available to
ensure people understand and i'll
reiterate it here today
it's not just a vaccine is obviously an
incredible medical breakthrough
and we want every american to have one
but even after that vaccinated
social distancing wearing masks are
going to be essential and
we'll need to continue communicating
about that through health and medical
experts
even after your vaccinated social
distancing and wearing masks will be
essential
that is what the white house press
secretary just told us
now it's the beginning of february 2021
it was 11 months ago that they told us
two weeks to flatten the curve
we all did it we all did everything we
came home with our bags from the
supermarket
after we had worn masks and gloves
and we washed our food and we did that
and then they locked us down in all the
different states
and they destroyed the economy and they
destroyed lives and they caused people
to be suicidal
they caused other people not to go get
pre-emptive
medical attention and all sorts of other
horrible things and alcohol rates went
up and people don't go to the gym
and all of these things then they
continued that with lockdowns throughout
the summer
now they want us to wear two masks
sometimes three masks then they'll also
tell us masks don't work and they do
work
and you should social distance while
they don't social distance and all
of the relentless endless hypocrisy that
these people
have have done to us and here's what
i've come to believe at this point
uh and again i just want to read you the
quote one more time even after you're
vaccinated social distancing and wearing
mass will be essential
guys really think about this 11 months
ago what were we told
two weeks to flatten the curve we are in
a very different world now and
that old world ain't coming back and the
the
conclusion that i have come to at this
point is there is a system in place
and i don't know everything about that
system but that system is pushing us
it is pushing us to see how far it can
push us before we all snap
and break now that is not a call for
violence or anything like it
it is a call for individual
responsibility
do what you gotta do in your life to
keep you and your family safe
okay but this sick and twisted
never-ending pushing of how we have to
live
and what we have to wear and who we can
be near and who we can invite into our
home
and that a year later two weeks to
flatten the curve now we're all gonna
get vaccinated
and we're still gonna socially distance
and wear masks it is completely bananas
it is completely bananas covet is not a
hoax
i actually i know somebody i had
somebody oh my well i don't want to say
too much but maybe i
had someone in my house yesterday who
had coveted over the last couple weeks
and she got sick
and then she got better and i know many
people that i know
that have gotten sick and then got
better and yes do some people die
some people do and we know that most of
those people
are elderly people 80s and upwards who
have two or three other
comorbidities okay they usually have
diabetes and
obesity not all of them and there are
some cases that younger people die of
course there are there is no perfect
system we cannot protect everyone
from everything if if you wanted to be
protected from everything all the time
you'd literally never leave your house
and you really couldn't even
do anything in your house you'd have to
sit in a room quietly in the dark all
the time
and that probably wouldn't be great for
you either but think about what they
have done here
they we know that old people die of this
usually with diabetes and obesity and
then what did they do
they said okay now you can't go to the
gym anymore don't go to the gym even
though we know obesity is part of this
thing
don't go to the gym oh and by the way
order in food all the time order and
take out all the time let's get let's
get you really sopped up there with some
sodium okay can we do that a lot of
fried food like what do you when people
are ordering it what are you usually
ordering it's like a burger and fries
it's pizza
tons of carbs breads chinese food which
is usually
sugary and all sorts of stuff it's like
what did they do to us
man freaking wake up already it's just
wake up these are not good people they
have some power over us i suppose but
i don't think for for that much longer i
think there is going to be a breaking
point and by the way we're seeing it
which is why i'm seriously freaking
proud and thrilled
that we are now less than a hundred
thousand votes away
or signatures away from recalling gavin
newsom
recall gavin newsom i'm not kidding
maybe i'll run for governor if this
thing goes through maybe i'll run for
governor
there's probably far better people than
me and my entire platform would be
whatever gavin said i say the reverse i
wouldn't raise a dime that would be it
i'll do a youtube show and see if we can
make it happen
i'm not sure i'm honestly not sure but
get rid of these people
they are not good people sue them sue
andrew cuomo for putting all the old
people
back in the old age homes okay these are
not good people anymore and it's not
gonna stop
and you think if you think man i'm on a
rant if you think it's gonna stop
if you think it is going to stop that a
year later okay two weeks to flatten the
curve now it's a year later 100 mask
mandate
and we're going to keep social
distancing and you're going to wear
masks and blah blah blah and we're going
to partially open things and maybe open
them and kind of open them
if you think that once they've pushed
you that far that they're gonna go
ah all right guys let them out freedom
for everybody
no it will be the next test there will
be super covid the uk strange something
happened in brazil
a guy banged a monkey now we're all in
trouble there's going to be
all sorts of crazy stuff that is what is
going to happen we are being pushed
to see how much of our individuality of
our freedom of our liberty we will give
away and i think our founders
here in the united states would be
pretty freaking depressed on on how
easily
we've done it but speaking of all of
that
story number four which fits perfectly
as a segue the cdc
again these people didn't want us to
wear masks at some point now they want
us to wear masks
believe science except when science
doesn't work blah blah blah
well they have uh released their rules
for super bowl parties the super bowl
is a big football game that happens once
a year it's happening
this sunday and they've given us some
rules related
to the super bowl and uh look nobody's
gonna pay attention to this nonsense and
you're really
my i'm not an expert so uh don't hold me
to account but
if you're doing most of these things
some you have a bigger problem you have
more of a psychological problem
than anything else here's a couple
things they want you to do for super
bowl parties if you're gonna dare have a
super bowl party
a super bowl party i think it's it's
super bowl what like 70 something maybe
or 62 or 59 something like that
we've always had super bowl parties
people used to get together they'd eat
nachos and they'd eat wings and they'd
drink beer it was the old days okay
they don't want you to have these super
bowl parties anymore um
so here's what they're saying about
super party wear a mask with
two or more layers to stop the spread of
kovid to protect yourself
and others okay so now you're gonna wear
two masks at the super bowl party where
you'd normally be drinking a beer
and eating wings in cold weather wear
your mask under your scarf ski mask or
baklava black lava what the hell's
baklava isn't that a greek dessert
what the hell is a balacavala
is that a type of ski mask
it's a type of ski max a balaclava i've
literally never heard of that
okay so all right everyone pause this
first oh you can't pause it's live but
i want you to google balachava right now
your b-l-a-c-l-a-v-a
why would you be wearing one of those to
a super bowl party unless you were going
to murder everybody
which i guess is against their rules too
your
your balaclava okay
so be it guests should avoid direct
contact don't shake anyone's hand people
if you shake your host's hand you might
kill
them uh including handshakes and hugs uh
with people that are not from your
household yeah yeah you know hugging and
human communication
any sort of touching almost everyone you
touch will die who is the
girl in uh was it rogue i think it was
rogue and x-men if she touched people
they would die yeah it was rogue thank
you my fat checkers are on it today
rogue remember rogue it was played by
what's her name who was in uh
you know what the hell is that girl's
name she was in the true blood
come on help me here guys she was in
true blood deleted true blood that girl
she was rogan x-men
and her power was that if she touched
you she could kill you so they're
they're
basically making us all rogue in x-men
give me that girl's name whatever her
name is
uh for a virtual celebration oh i love
this one if you're gonna have a virtual
super bowl party
schedule a time to eat a meal together
virtually
and have people show their main dish
vegetable or dessert all right let's be
very clear about this there are no
vegetables at super bowl parties
yes does somebody always have a little
thing of carrots
over there with some dip yes they do and
those people should not be invited to
parties i
i agree with that okay those people can
have their own
vegan special parties but you
hi i'm on zoom at the super bowl party
it's the second quarter great game you
want to see my carrot
oh for [ __ ] sake um oh here's here we
go
what's that girl's name anna paquin
that's it okay i'm beating you to the
punch here you've got a computer what's
going on oh there it is i had a packard
okay
avoid shouting cheering loudly or
singing
clap stomp your feet or bring or provide
handheld noisemakers instead
avoid shouting cheering loudly or
singing
clap stomp your feet these are we are
keep background music volume low so
guests don't need to shout
keep it low keep it cool uh i assume i'm
surprised they didn't give us the type
of music we're allowed to listen to
you'd want sort of a something melodic
and soft
ambient chill check out the chill
channel on spotify i like the chill
channel
just keep it cool you know what i mean
talk like this
like you're an asmr person
just talk like this oh did you see tom
brady
just threw a 17-yard touchdown pass
to that guy i don't really watch anymore
so i don't know who he is
uh okay can i please have a wing now
i'll go sit in the basement and eat it
quietly thank you
uh and finally offered no touch trash
cans for guests
to easily throw away food items yes it
is true
uh here at my house we have one of those
trash cans that you have to pull
it's under the sink you you pull out the
drawer and the trash can is there it is
a covered super spreader
almost everyone i know that has visited
me over the last few weeks is dead now
because they touch my garbage can
ladles and jelly spoons that was the
reuben report direct message
for today february 4th was it february
4th
2021 may god help us all
i look forward to communicating with you
for the rest of the day
at rubinreport.locals.com and tomorrow
our panel will be with eric mataxis
rabbi david wolpe and peter bogosian
part two of my interview with andy noe
is up right now on youtube and the full
episode is up
at rubinreport.locals.com
speak quietly don't touch anyone
speak quietly don't touch anyone
or you're a murderer see you tomorrow
you